russia is actively silencing citizens
who post about the war in ukraine from
pictures of the bombed maripo theater to
comments that call out the invasion
the new fakes law that went into effect
in march has made this targeting easy
and authorities have taken action
against more than two thousand one
hundred people in and outside of russia
michael nache is a popular youtube
personality now living in lithuania if
he steps foot back home in russia he can
face up to 10 years in prison i just try
to inform people about everything that
is going on especially russian politics
i believe that it's important now i'm
sure that it's important after russian
government started
to
just
to try to get me to jail and so when did
you find out about your court case
so i read it about it in use nobody send
me anything and after that uh
our own government outdoor organization
they
suggest for me their advocate and after
that we
we get this case looking over the
documents we saw that the expertise
trials use photos from instagram
wikipedia and screenshots of michael's
youtube and juxtaposed them with his
passport photos to determine his
personality the court documents also
grab specifics from his video to show
they created a false montage to
disseminate fake information about the
russian army
the situation gets a lot bleaker for
those inside the country with many in
detention centers
recently the first sentence assigned for
anti-war commentary gave alexey gordinov
seven years in prison
arrests relating to freedom of
expression in russia have been growing
steadily since 2006 but since the
invasion of ukraine the scale and
severity have surpassed any prior
censorship efforts one can look to the
adherents of social networks to see how
successful the kremlin's grip on
information has been
supported
and local tech companies are complying
vk and yandex have been blocking
accounts even western companies are
under scrutiny with some taking a
voluntary approach to moderation youtube
removed videos from tiktok influencers
with lana sokov a russian living in
spain who regularly criticized the
government after russia's investigative
unit requested that she be taken offline
later she found out that she had been
charged with extremism
[Music]
so where do you think all of this is
headed
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you